And something I'll talk about in the
book as well is we never had sex. We
were married for three years and my body
just like could not have sex. My body
was like you will not enter. My body
just was like shut down. Just like like
it couldn't nothing could enter.
You got used for 195 days daily.
From a juvenile when my clothes had
holes in them and my afro was picky to
them. Mosino and Versace. No laces in a
brothers and sisters and dear friends.
Hope you guys are well. I'm here with
how you doing mate.
Alhamdulillah.
You want some? I'll give you let me know
in well you know some people want some
they get it and some people want some
and they get nothing.
They don't. No,
they don't. Okay. So this is this here
was a violation emotional damage.
Yes. Okay. This maybe explains why Nas
Daily the failure uh of his people.
But before before you even get into Naz
Daily, for the people that don't know
Nas Daily, Nas Daily is somebody who is
a traitor.
Yeah. Well, he's born in Palestine.
However, he's been used as a porn by the
Israelis to whitewash their crimes. In
fact, he has whitewashed the crimes so
much and let the side down that you have
ADL. Yeah. That lobby group of uh
Israel. Not ADL. No, no, no. He's ADL.
He's a ADL and they gave him an award
for, you know, when Israel is giving you
an award, you know something's not
right.
You become the scum of the scum.
Yeah. And that's why a lot of people
despise that guy. And he claims to be
Muslim, doesn't know about Islam,
marries a Mormon, but uh what what
became of that relationship?
I don't know. But I'm curious. There
must be something that must have
frustrated him as a man that he must
have certain desires that could not be
fulfilled that caused him to take his
frustration out in different ways by
backstabbing his people.
Are you talking about dessert?
No, I'm talking about desires.
Ah, tastes better than dessert in a way.
Of course.
Come on.
So, this is what his wife had to say. Or
should we say his ex-wife? Let's Let's
got to be precise.
Let's Let's see.
My name is Alen and I am divorced. I
grew up, got married and hoped for the
happy ending. But sadly, after 3 years
of trying our hardest, it didn't work
out and we ended up divorcing. After one
year, something happened and it was like
a big breaking point. Then we stayed
married two more years and then he just
I don't know I don't know what happened
after those two years. We've been
together 3 years and it just happened.
And something I'll talk about in the
book as well is we never had sex. We
were married for 3 years and my body
just like could not have sex. I think
because of being religious for so long.
That's so interesting.
The shame and weird things associated
and it happens to a lot of religious
women
that when they get married it's like oh
your whole life you're like shameful
shameful cover your body. Shame shame.
Wait you're wait sorry I just realized
you're supposed to have sex when you get
married.
Yeah but we I couldn't.
You're supposed to have sex.
It was your choice to not have sex or
it wasn't a choice. My body was like you
will not enter. My body just was like
shut down. Just like like it couldn't
nothing could enter. Logical thing.
So that's why he broke up with you.
NO THAT'S NOT WHY THAT'S NOT WHY. NO,
that's not why. That's not
That's definitely why he broke up WITH
YOU.
NO, IT'S NOT. HE COULD HAVE DONE IT
AFTER one year.
He could No, no. I I know him. I know
him. He did not because of that. I
promise you. 3 years. You would do it
after 6 months. For a woman's body, you
need to be relaxed.
Yes.
You need to be relaxed.
And when you are raised with all these
negative messages around sex
and like cover your body, cover your
chest, cover your shoulders.
Brainwashed to be scared of sex kind of.
Yeah. It happens to a lot of women. It
happens to a lot of a lot of Orthodox
Jewish women. There's such a shame
around sex. Shame, shame, shame. Like,
you're a If you have sex, you're
a bad person.
And so then you get married one day
and now you're supposed to be go from
the virgin to the sexy person.
And my body just couldn't. It was very
weird. It was very weird because I am
also a like I am a sexual person. Like
what she said was not nice.
Not nice.
So I mean this is an absolute utter
humiliation. I mean as a man you know
you you feel emasculated. You feel you
feel feminine. You feel like a woman. I
mean imagine you are married to a woman
and for 3 years I mean we need to my
math is
you can't even say you you feel like a
woman because even women you know they
have desires and they meet their desires
but when they're married to a real man
that is
so that's 195 days of not intimacy
that's some quick maths
that's quick maths 195 days guys just
imagine that for 1 days
I don't want to imagine that
I mean you can't you know this person
had no intimacy and let me be honest we
understand you know a bit of woman's
psychology here and there. Uh, that
woman did not love you, my friend. That
woman had no attraction to you
whatsoever. I don't know what she was
with you for. Maybe the money, maybe the
fame, maybe whatever it is, or maybe,
you know,
because Mosad told her to.
Oh, yep. Definitely 100%. There is no
surprises there. Let me tell you
something. Because for her to say, cuz
it gets worse. She said she had worse
than that.
Oh, bro, it gets worse. You know why?
Imagine you was with a woman for that
long.
She did not have any intimacy with you.
She gave you nothing. And then after you
broke up, she went and got something.
A you know what that shows you? That
shows you that you are a coward. You are
You're not even a man.
You're not only getting used by Israel,
you're getting used by women as well.
Bro, that was deep. I think the video
needs to end there. That that hurt me. I
feel the pain. Yeah, you are a coward.
I'm doing this video. You know why? Cuz
I want to hit a nerve, bro. I wish I can
see you in person, bro. Well, I hope I
make dua, but I come face to face with
you. Yeah, you're an emasculated coward.
You've backstabbed your people. Not only
that, you was married to a woman. I
think she might be Jewish, by the way.
Not like ethnic ethnically Jewish. This
is unbelievable.
She claims to be a Mormon, though.
Yeah, that's religiously. Yeah, but
ethnically she might be Jewish. So the
point is this. Yeah, let me tell you
something. I wouldn't be surprised if
Mosai paid her and said, "Listen, keep
this guy busy. He's a little misky and
full clown. What a joke." Yeah. Backs up
his people, bro. Someone who doesn't
stand up for his own people will we'll
fall for anything. And they probably
said to her, you know, just keep him
busy. Yeah. And guess what? Because for
that woman to not give him any intimacy
and for him to still be with her as well
rather than leaving her
for 3 years and then afterwards you
leave her or she leaves you or she's
probably happy give you she probably use
as a to you left and then she goes and
what does she admit? She said she is not
a virgin anymore. Meaning she went and
she said boyfriends. So, and then she
she checks out she didn't give it to her
husband and she got it from boyfriends.
I mean for a man I don't know that is
what is more painful than knowing that
he was emasculating.
I'm surprised he was with her for more
than a day or nay even a week.
Bro, I'm surprised she stayed with him
of a man like this. What a coward he is.
And let me tell you something. Nas nas
daily. You got used for 195 days daily.
Oh,
that was natural. That came from the
heart. That came from the heart. That's
why it felt That's why he has those days
in there. Yeah, that's the days. You're
a coward, man. I hope this video burns
you. Yes, just the way you turned your
back on your people. I hope this burns
you. I hope it hits a nerve. That's
exactly why I've done it, inshallah.
Yeah. You are a scumbag. You are a dirt.
That's what you are. Let me tell you
something. You're an intellectual coward
as well. Yes, she used you. Israel is
using you. You're going to carry and
use. You have no legs to stand on. And
you're going to go down in history as a
shameful person if you don't repent and
change your ways. Allah is always
merciful. And just like you turned your
back on Palestine, your ex turned uh her
back on
your ex turned her back on you
but turned Israel will turn its back on
you as well.
Yes. That's all we have to say brother
and sisters. Till next timealamikum
inshallah. May Allah make us real men
that our wives do not um reject us to
that level. Alhamdulillah.